[Music]
when your wives suggested couples
therapy do you think this is what they
had in mind
definitely we were a couple of couples
right Ted enough of the delusions he
didn't time-travel and you didn't go to
heaven and hell there's a real idea for
you be role models to your daughters get
real jobs yeah
we've spent our whole life trying to
reunite the world and I'm tired dude Ted
we have a destiny to fulfill Oh
greetings my excellent friends we have a
problem step forward a song created by
Preston Logan
performed tonight will save reality as
we know it
oh good you better write that so now why
can't we just go to the future when we
have written it take it from ourselves
except won't that be stealing cheers I
was stealing we're stealing it from
ourselves
[Music]
do four that's a total into you
[Applause]
way how's it going dude Ted we're
putting together a most extraordinary
bag
you gonna beat her BAM
we're gonna go talk to death is he
playing hopscotch by yourself dude is
cheating hey death
life isn't a wild stallion let's rock
[Music]
excellent to each other party on dude
[Music]
are you doing well you know dad and
we're in hell but how you doing
[Music]